hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering your property
investment questions so that you have
the best
2021 ever i want you to kill it this
year in property and the thing that's
going to stop you killing it in property
is having obstacles or questions that
are unanswered
well that's why on samuel lee's youtube
channel i answer your questions
every single sunday at 7 00 p.m on q a
sunday so
any questions you've got about property
comment them below
in the comment box and then i will do my
very best to answer
your property investment questions if
you're not subscribed to the channel
do that now hit the like button and
let's get started so
dan mccoozy says is it possible to
manage a rent to rent hmo
whilst living there renting out the
other three rooms if so
how did you go about by doing this and
what made the contracts look like
dan that is a brilliant strategy in fact
this is if i was going back starting
again and i was like 17 years old
i would tell myself to do exactly that
i would rent a property off of a
landlord tell the landlord you're going
to be living there
get a good rent but get permission to
rent out the other rooms
this is just genius and if you don't
mind having other tenants in the house
in terms of contracts i mean you could
just use normal contracts
normal or you could have a lodger
agreement
so you could that's a really good
question about contracts
don't worry about the detail find the
landlord
that will be prepared to let you do that
and then find the contracts but i
imagine you'd probably you could either
have a normal rent to rent agreement
where you're the management company but
you're also one of the tenants
uh that'll probably be the smartest way
because you wouldn't want to sublet
so you need to make sure the contracts
were right but it's a great strategy
love it love it love it love it and i
also love it when i'm like
caught off guard by a question that was
such a good question i love it put your
comments
questions thoughts below in the box
louise
smith sorry louis smith if you had one
million pounds to invest what would you
do with it
um well for a start i'd put it in
property obviously
because this is a property channel and
secondly i do have a million
pounds to invest in fact you probably
you've probably seen me invest a million
pounds on the youtube channel
i mean i bought i i used um a million
pounds
i publicly did a video where i built six
houses from scratch
that cost me 830 000 pounds but i had
over a million pounds profit in it once
it was done
so um yeah development property
brr everything's the same just add a
couple extra zeros
if i'm teaching you how to buy a house
for 50 grand spend 20 grand adding value
to it and then refinance it at 100 grand
do the same story but add an extra zero
or add a couple extra zeros in fact the
bigger deals they get easier because
there's more profit i mean there's more
profit
you can pay people to do stuff you can't
pay people to do stuff when you're
making 20 grand whoa you're making 20
grand out of the deal
let's do everything yourself making 200
grand out the deal
you can start paying interior designers
you can pay specialists architects
and it just it just comes off of the
profit which means that it's much easier
smoother ride
so it's good to have a million pounds to
invest i like it
next clash what's the lowest rental
yield you'd accept for a rental property
so i don't really work in yields i tend
to work in return on investment
yield is the value of the property
and then you look at the annual rent and
you divide the two together
so it doesn't really matter what the
yield is i've heard people say this is
giving me a
you know a seven percent yield isn't it
amazing and it's like yeah but
it's a hmo property and you've got to
pay the bills and the council tax and
the management your return on
investments
rubbish so it's all about
cash on cash return on investment uh it
also depends on how passive you want it
to be
if you're building a big warehouse for
amazon and you want amazon to become
your tenant
they're not going to pay you a high
yield but they're going to sign a
20-year lease
and it's going to be completely passive
so you've got to factor in time and
different things
typically i look for a 20 return on
investment as a minimum hope that helps
hey guys if you enjoyed the video do me
a favor hit the like button that'd be
really cool
tony tate what's the best way to find
investors for deal sourcing
so finding them isn't the problem tony
tony tate they're everywhere you just if
you go to a property networking
association
or go to come to my property investors
crash course you see hundreds of people
that are
wanting to invest in property or are
investing in property
you go online you can just join my
facebook group property investors with
samuel leads 29
000 people finding them is not the
problem the problem is getting them to
want to buy from you how do you do that
you gotta start by asking questions
asking them the right questions
filtering them qualifying them and then
adding value and having good deals
you know so i hope that helps razvan
gabriel how would you invest 30 000
pounds as a beginner would you focus on
brr projects
so you could pull out all your money or
would you just go for a hmo because it's
safe
it's only not safe when you don't know
what you're doing
if i had 30 grand and i knew what i was
doing which i would do
i'd be wanting to do hmo and brr combine
the two
so if you don't know what you're doing
and you think oh i need to play it safe
don't try and be safe try and get more
educated blm
yolo can you explain how a mortgage
works and how you pay off your mortgage
after selling the house you use the
mortgage to pay for while still keeping
some of the profit
real simple blm yolo so if you've got a
mortgage on a house
that means you've got a loan against the
house if you've got a loan against the
house
that lender that loaned you the money
is going to have a charge on the house
which means that when you sell the
property
you're gonna have to before you take any
profit you're gonna have to pay back
that loan to the lender so if the
mortgage is 75 grand and the house is
worth 100 grand
when you sell it you're going to get 25
for you you have to give back the 75.
if the house doubles in value it becomes
worth 200 000 pounds
no problem you have to pay back the 75
you keep the 125. that's how it works
and every month you have to pay a little
bit of interest
for having the loan you might be on a
repayment mortgage where you're paying
down the mortgage slowly but that's how
it works
hope that helps abdullah
hi samuel do you suggest getting some
real life experience as a young
teenager not theory yeah i suggest
getting some experience
work experience work don't work for
money work for experience
don't trade your time for money trade
your time for for experience 100
what do you think about taking a
business degree in business i think it
sucks
that's probably a little bit brash i've
never done it so i can't say for sure
but what i will say is i know a lot of
people that go to university to study
business and real estate
and the people that are teaching have no
passion
they haven't done it themselves now
listen if you want to do that that's
fine if you want to pay 9 000 pounds a
semester to learn from someone that's
teaching stuff they've not done that's
fine is it a problem i don't want to do
that
i want to learn from someone that's
lived it breathed it got the t-shirt
has a passion for teaching i spoke to a
guy just yesterday who was on a
studying realistic at university i was
like
what are you learning
why aren't you financially independent
why haven't you got any property deals
why
aren't you making any money oh what have
you been studying were you there
yesterday yo
yesterday what did you study oh we're
talking about the technology that goes
inside windows
the technology that goes inside windows
that's not going to get you rich depends
on what you want abdullah
if you want to go and get a business
degree because you want to impress your
parents and you want to look at the
degree you want to go look at that man
all right then go do it you want to be
smart in business you want to make money
study money learn how to make money hang
around millionaires hang out people that
are rich
how about people that want you to be
rich don't hang around people that just
are there because they've been paid to
be there and they've never done it it's
a joke
it's my opinion amina what are your
thoughts on handing over a property to a
housing association or local council for
guaranteed rent
amino i think it's great i've got lots
of my houses on with
housing associations you're going to get
a little bit less rent but you're going
to be helping you're going to be giving
back you'll be providing houses for the
homeless for the vulnerable
and it's quite hands-off and passive so
i do that with
one in 10 of my houses mohammed sabi
ahmad
100 agree with you samuel that people
who still live with their parents their
mature adults playing playstation is
shockingly embarrassing
i don't actually remember saying that i
probably did sounds like the kind of
thing i would say
i would ask you how you motivate them to
push them out
and get them to go and look for deals if
they're just bums
i don't try i i
i just put out my content
to everybody if they chew i'm not going
to go after and target people that are
lazy and unmotivated
playing the playstation on their home i
just put youtube videos out for whoever
wants to watch them
and in fact the opposite if i've got
students if i'm at a program
i'm going to invest my time into people
that are actually taking action and
winning
i'm not going to spend my time trying to
persuade somebody who's
losing who's choosing to not do well
who's
just not doing anything i'm not going to
try and persuade somebody
who's not putting into action what i'm
teaching them
i'm not going to try and persuade them
no come on do it do it do it instead
i'm going to teach everybody the same
thing then i want to find the people
that are taking action and getting
results
and then i'm going to spend time with
them because i'm attracted to success
i'm attracted to like it's like saying
with investment if i've got 20 grand
i put 10 grand here 10 grand there if
this 10 grand does really well i'm going
to put more money into it
if a student does really well i'll spend
more time with them i'm going to spend
more time people are taking action and
people that are winning
all right last question mohamed says is
it better to
lease or buy things for your hmo such as
sofas washing
etc is it better to lease or buy i would
say
probably it's smarter to lease when
normally when you lease furniture what
happens is
depends on the deal that you get of
course but often what happens is you'll
lease it for five years
and then you'll just pay a small monthly
fee and at the end of the five years
it's
yours to keep so that's often how it
works now if you add up how much you
paid for it over the five years it's a
lot more expensive than just buying it
outright
but you didn't have to shell out a lot
of money to start with
which means you've got more initial
money to put down into more properties
and you're paying for the furniture
month by month and who's paying for it
the tenants are paying for it
so it's probably smarter and you're
going to put down
less money up front to lease it but of
course you are going to get
less monthly cash flow if you do that
because you have to be paying for the
furniture so it really just depends on
how much cash you've got
if you've not got much cash and you're
on a budget lease the furniture
if you've got the cash you want to buy
it go ahead and buy it i do both i've
done both i continue to do both
so anyway folks i hope you enjoyed this
video i hope you found it helpful
i want to see you win in 2020. so what
are the questions
that are stopping you what are the
things that you need to know to push you
to the next level
i want to help you comment it below any
questions you've got there's no question
too big
there's no question too small there's no
question too complex there's no question
too stupid
just comment it below i'll do my best to
help subscribe
like the video i'll see you next time
[Music]